>> Marie: JOE BIDEN HECKLED
AGAIN WHILE STOPPING ON THE
CAMPAIGN TRAIL.
>> THIS IS NOT A TRUMP RALLY.
I AGREE WITH YOU, NICE TALKING
TO YOU.
THIS IS A DEMOCRACY.
LET HER GO.
>> Marie: AT THE FORMER
VICE PRESIDENT IS REVERSING
COURSE AFTER CAUSING SOME
CONTROVERSY COMING AFTER BIDEN
SAID HE WOULD NOT HONOR THE
SENATE IMPEACHMENT TRIAL
SUBPOENA SAYING IT WOULD
DISTRACT FROM PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
BEHAVIOR.
SO LAWRENCE, A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS ON THE SUBPOENA.
THE FIRST IS THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION HAS IGNORED A
COUPLE OF SUBPOENAS FROM THE
HOUSE.
THEY DID NOT SEND SEVERAL PEOPLE
TO TESTIFY.
WHY SHOULD BIDEN?
>> Lawrence: CHALLENGES IN THE
COURT AND SEPARATION OF POWER.
>> Marie: THE SECOND QUESTION
IS, THE SENATE TRAILERS TO
JUDGE PRESIDENT TRUMP'S BEHAVIOR
AND SOUL OF JOE BIDEN'S BEHAVIOR
IS NOT PART OF THE IMPEACHMENT
ARTICLE.
>> Lawrence: IT BUT THIS IS
WHERE THE CENTER OF THIS STARTED
ACCORDING TO DEMOCRATS BECAUSE
HE WANTED DIRT ON HIS OPPONENT'S
HOME BRING HIM IN.
BUT LET'S TALK ABOUT JOE BIDEN
BECAUSE HE FLIP-FLOPPED.
FIRST HE SAID HE WASN'T GOING TO
APPEAR AND THEN HE SAID HE WAS
GOING TO APPEAR BUT HE HAS A BIG
PROBLEM.
HE STILL DOESN'T HAVE AN ANSWER
ON THE HUNTER BIDEN THING.
THIS DISMISSIVENESS WILL WORK
WITH THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA RIGHT
NOW, BUT WHEN YOU GET ON THE
GENERAL STAGE, YOU WILL HAVE TO
ANSWER TO THEM.
DONALD TRUMP WILL GO BLOW FOR
BLOW.
SO HE WILL KEEP THE QUESTION
UNTIL HE'S OFFICIALLY ANSWERED
IT.
AND YOU KNOW, HUNTER'S BABY MAMA
MIGHT GET THE ANSWER BEFORE HE
DOES.
>> I'M NOT SURE THAT HAS
ANYTHING TO DO WITH IT, BUT WE
ARE ABOUT TO START AN
IMPEACHMENT TRIAL ON THE SENATE.
HOW ARE WE LOOKING FORWARD TO
WHAT'S COMING IN THE NEW YEAR?
>> IT'S NOT SO UNCOMMON THAT
THIS IT ACTUALLY DOES OCCUR.
LOOKING FORWARD TO 2020 AND THE
IMPEACHMENT TRIALS, I WOULD LIKE
TO SAY, INQUIRING AMERICANS WANT
TO KNOW, HOW DIRTY IS JOE BIDEN?
THE UKRAINIAN CALL IS, TRUMP
SUSPECTS CORRUPTION.
IS THERE CORRUPTION THERE?
IS THERE CORRUPTION THERE THAT
INVOLVES A FORMER
VICE PRESIDENT, NOW PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATE?
AND I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW THAT AT
THIS POINT.
I WOULD LIKE TO SEE IF
VICE PRESIDENT BIDEN COMES AND
ANSWER THOSE QUESTIONS BECAUSE I
DO THINK WHEN THERE IS SMOKE
THERE IS FIRE AND THERE MIGHT BE
SOMETHING THERE.
>> Marie: EMILY, DO YOU THINK
WE SHOULD HAVE WITNESSES IN THIS
TRIAL?
>> I THINK THAT'S FRANKLY UP TO
THE G.O.P. STRATEGY IT AND THE
WHITE HOUSE STRATEGY, WHETHER OR
NOT THEY FEEL THAT WITNESSES
WILL BE BENEFICIAL TO THEIR
CASE.
>> SHOULD IT BE THOUGH?
SHOULD THAT BE THE QUESTION?
OR SHOULD IT BE A FIERCE TRIAL?
>> I THINK ONE ISSUE THAT I HAVE
WITH BIDEN'S COMMENTS ABOUT THE
LEGITIMACY OF THE CONGRESSIONAL
OVERSIGHT, IS THAT AN AVERAGE
AMERICAN DOESN'T SEE IT AS AS
TRIBAL A STICK AS THESE GUYS ARE
MAKING IT OUT TO BE.
THAT'S TRANSPARENCY ON BOTH
SIDES AND, I THINK ALL OF US
WILL BELIEVE MORE IN THE ENTIRE
PROCESS.
IT WOULD BE MORE IF EVERYONE
INVOLVED WOULD, JUST A LITTLE
BIT SUPPORT THE PROCESS ITSELF.
SO WE HURRIED UP BIDEN, A DOUBLE
BACK ON HIS COMMENTS AND SAID,
HERE'S WHAT I MEANT.
I ALWAYS COMPLIED WITH LAWFUL
CONGRESSIONAL OVERSIGHT BUT THIS
ISN'T THAT.
HOW ARE ARE WE SUPPOSED TO THEN
TAKE THAT WHEN THERE ARE
HUNDREDS OF ELECTED OFFICIALS UP
THERE?
WE CAN'T BLACK-AND-WHITE IT.
FINAL POINT, THIS ISN'T A TRUMP
RALLY, IT'S MORE FURTHER IN THAT
NARRATIVE OF US VERSUS THEM, WE
ARE BETTER THAN THEM, THESE GUYS
AS THE VOTES MATTER LESS IN
THEIR OPINION MATTERS LAST ON
THAT CONTEMPT WAS GOING TO CARRY
THROUGH THE ELECTION AND
ULTIMATELY WOULD BE BENEFICIAL.
>> Marie: I KNOW YOU ARE ALL
LOOKING FORWARD TO THIS, HOW ARE
YOU HANDICAPPING WHAT WE WILL
SEE IN THE SENATE?
>> IT BECOMES MORE AND MORE
CLEAR.
BUT THE PRESIDENT WANTED
INVESTIGATIONS TO TAKE PLACE IN
THE UKRAINE AND WE ALL KNOW THAT
AT THIS POINT BUT THE PRESS
KEEPS CALLING THEM POLITICALLY
BENEFICIAL TO DONALD TRUMP.
AT THE SAME TIME THEY SAY, THE
JOE BIDEN THING IS A CONSPIRACY
THEORY.
WELL, IF HIS CONSPIRACY THEORY
THAN IT WOULD BE POLITICALLY
BENEFICIAL TO JOE BIDEN TO
INVESTIGATE, NOT DONALD TRUMP.
DO YOU GUYS SEE THAT FUNDAMENTAL
LOGIC PROBLEM THAT WE ARE ALL
GOING TO BE EXPERIENCING WHEN
JOE BIDEN HAS TO FACE UP TO THE
STUFF?
IF DONALD TRUMP WANTED
INVESTIGATIONS AND IF JOE BIDEN
WAS CLEAR THE INVESTIGATIONS
WOULD BENEFIT JOE BIDEN.
>> Marie: ONE OF THE
INTERESTING THINGS HE SAID AND
ONE OF THE WITNESSES AS PART OF
THE HOUSE HEARINGS,
PRESIDENT TRUMP JUST WANTED SOME
POLITICAL ARGUMENT.
>> AT SOME POINT YOU HAVE TO
INVESTIGATE.
>> IT'S NOT A FACT, THAT'S WHAT